Italy, famous for its luxury brands, is
facing a major problem, a shortage of
artisans, the very skilled workers whose
expertise makes these products.
In the town of Fernley, Italy, luxury
brand Fendi thinks it's found a solution
training school students.
From master painters of the Renaissance
to leather makers in Tuscany, Italy is
renowned for its master craftsman.
So when Search Brunschwig came to Rome to
come find his new chief executive in
2018, he was surprised to find there was
a major issue with the workforce, a
shortage of artisans.
If we want to do more objects, we need
more people.
A generation goes, where is the next
generation?
Lack of artisans isn't just an Italian
issue.
From a dearth of blacksmiths in
Australia to much of Europe's luxury
sector, countries are struggling to
train and retain sufficient numbers of
people in key industries.
But in Italy, the problem is
particularly acute.
According to luxury trade group,
Altagamma, there are about 240000
students enrolled in professional
schools in France.
Almost 900000 in Germany.
And only about 17000 in Italy.
And yet, Italy's current youth
unemployment rate stands at 24 percent.
This is where Brunswick happened.
as a foreigner
we ask a few questions like, is there a
technical apprenticeship in there?
Does it exist?
And the fact hardly exists.
This is firmly a center of Italian shoe
making that started as far back as the
15th century.
It is here that Fendi built a new
factory and started recruiting young
people onto their production lines run
by Atagamma in collaboration with Italy's
Education Ministry by young people.
In the last two years, a trade school
can take internships at companies like
Fendi, Bulgari and Gucci.
Despite initial skepticism, the
apprenticeship scheme is starting to
change attitudes to factory work.
Entry level positions in the
sector can start to around 1000 to 1200
years net per month, according to off
camera, which isn't a lot, but is
comparable to starting salaries in many
of his jobs in Italy.
So it's Fendi.
Paying students enough? I don't think is
an issue.
I mean, again, if they are young in
their first job waiting for a salary
that you get typically for Fendi and the
residents of firm, no, they the
opportunities in shoe making are
changing perceptions and boosting
business.
How do you make you know this city with
a future if you don't create local jobs
there, which could be done by the local
people.